well I mean I you know I I don't know
that I would know how to answer that
because if it wasn't for FL I mean I
don't think I'd ever have the visit the
gumption to do a Kickstarter campaign
because I am a loner and a lot of
writers that I know are loners and you
know and also I mean this is the other
thing that I feel like it takes a lot of
energy to write a good script and you
know and you have to be in a room a lot
alone and I don't know that I could
write properly it I also had to do that
I couldn't it's it would be so draining
like if I have a lunch even if it's a
girlfriend or something and I very
rarely do I very rarely go out and have
you know business lunches are I'm wiped
for the day it's draining you know and
to present yourself and he's doing it
because as a director it's it's a more
forceful I think persona anyway but if I
when when young writer you know pull me
and say you know how do i get my strip
shown or seen or read I deeply believe
that if a script is good it will
eventually get red doesn't mean it's
going to get made but it like the first
scripts i wrote they never got made but
they introduced me to people that then
would say hey I really like that strip I
can't make that one but would you be you
know and I think young writers it's very
compelling for them to ensue ductive for
them to go hmm what's on trend this week
let me write that but if they don't
write something that is personally
revealing you know even if it's you know
a gothic mystery or sci-fi you know
whatever whatever direction if it
doesn't reveal them and their voice then
it's
just like a thousand other scripts that
are trying to catch the trend of the day
and they're they're functional and bland
you know and I just say to the writer
because I'm sure everybody you know
there's so many ambitious you know if
the most ambitious people from every
high school come here
you